[Music]
hi my name is Richard I'm the owner of
Whole Foods here in East Village so we
make Taiwanese traditional beef noodle
soup in Taiwan there's many different
kinds you know a beef soup shop are like
pizza parlors in New York City every
neighborhood has one we make ours very
homestyle that's red cooked or fermented
broad bean paste raw sugar our own blend
of spices that dissin Oland warming you
know this dish was originally from the
soldiers who came from parts of China
and Szechuan you know they wanted a
taste of home and originally there was a
noodles in there was a beef dish but
there was so poor that they had to add
some doodles to make a dish that was of
sustenance and after the first phone was
made became so popular now it's the
national dish of Taiwan the most
important part about making beef noodle
soup it's just a lot of patience you
know soup is a slow process we start off
we use mostly shin bones you know we let
that go for an entire day and then
afterwards we add oro blend of spices a
star anis cloves such on better corns
cinnamon goji berries white peppercorns
black peppercorns and a few other things
in there too we actually cook the beef
separately with aromatics the Asian
Trinity ginger garlic onions fermented
broad bean paste rock sugar gives it a
nice glistening texture and look we put
a couple different types of soy sauce
aged soy sauce and dark soy sauce and
then from there we add in the beef
shanks you stir-fry it you know it cooks
the outside of the meat a little bit you
know it helps Brown it just a little bit
and then we add a little bit of water we
braise it and one of the most important
parts about that process is that after
you cook it you let it chill you know
you really want to let it settle and
reabsorb all the liquid that's been
braised and to keep it juicy and
flavorful and then from there we cook
noodles you know Tommy salvete noodles
are are very different than Phan doodles
or ramen noodles you know Tommy noodles
are made with flour water salt that's it
and what you're really looking for
there's a silky texture and you want it
to be chewy
we add in
a beef tallow and bone marrow mixture we
pull the noodle out put it in the beef
mixture we toss them then we add our
scallions then we add our meat then we
add this soup on a garnish it and try to
do as quickly as possible to get in the
kitchen to your table that's it I grew
up in Los Angeles
more specifically San Gabriel Valley you
know it's a place where when Pizza Hut
goes out of business you know a Chinese
restaurant goes in and I'm not
exaggerating there's maybe a thousand
Chinese restaurants where I grew up with
and you know we had really authentic
Tony's restaurants you know different
types whether it was a quick stir-fry or
a noodle shop and not knowing much about
American food besides like going to edit
out or something like that so we really
just kind of embedded and soaked in the
Asian culture you know this is how we
grew up eating and we wanted to share
that with everyone in New York City as
best we can
you
[Music]